pourquoi je crois encore la droite parce
que malgré nos épreuves la droite porte
qu'on elle cette France que je porte en
moi cette France des valeurs aussi du
travail qui rend digne des racines qui
rendent fort cette France de l'honneur
parce que rien ne peut tenir debout sans
ces convictions qui nous tiennent trop
souvent la droite à reculer je ne
reculerai pas relevons la droite pour
relever la France relevons ce qui fera
demain sa prospérité la liberté relevant
notre état pour qu'il protège et
relevons notre drapeau relevons notre
fierté celle d'appartenir à une grande
nation produit d'une grande civilisation
soyons prêts pour la France avec de
nouvelles idées avec un nouveau parti
plus moderne plus démocratique aussi car
je veux que pour se donner un nouvel
élan la droite vous redonne la parole à
vous les militants
vous êtes le coeur battant de la droite
vous êtes le cœur ardent de la France
ensemble faisons battre nos cœurs
français pour la droite et pour la
France
[Applaudissements]
il faut respecter les consignes que
vient de nous donner notre président
je voudrais justement mes amis en vous
remerciant d'être venu nombreux avoir
mon premier mot pour Annie Annie notre
présidente qui a fait le job elle a été
pendant toute cette campagne
elle a été pendant toute cette campagne
un formidable paratonnerre
et ce que je veux dire parce que on
craint toujours les campagnes internes
ça peut toujours présenter des risques
mais dans une campagne interne il y a un
énorme avantage Annie c'est qu'au bout
du compte on est sûr que c'est LR qui
gagne ça c'est pas mal je voudrais
je voudrais donc vous remercier surtout
saluer chaque membre les personnalités
bien sûr mais aussi chaque membre de
notre conseil national parce que vous
êtes en réalité le cœur battant mais
surtout le Parlement quelque sorte de
notre mouvement et demain je veux vous
donner un rôle plus important
qu'aujourd'hui je voudrais aussi vous
remercier vous saluer parce que pour moi
vous êtes une droite déterminée non
seulement une droite déterminée mais une
droite assumée une droite de droite tout
simplement
je voudrais saluer Aurélien saluer
par correspondance si j'ose dire
Eric redire et répéter redire et répéter
que
Eric Aurélien sont pour moi des
compétiteurs mais ça n'est pas des
adversaires dans mon parcours politique
les adversaires que j'ai pu affronter
ils ont toujours été à gauche
dans mon parcours politique
le combat mes adversaires c'est à gauche
mais le combat ça a toujours été pour la
droite et aujourd'hui je me suis engagé
aussi parce que le combat c'est pour la
droite française parce qu'on joue on
joue gros par son joue notre avenir et
que ma conviction et même ma certitude
c'est l'heure est venue leur est venue
d'une rupture d'une rupture franche
franche avec la double impasse qui nous
a emmené là où on en est aujourd'hui
une double rupture donc l'entre-soi et
l'entre-deux
l'entre-soi des décisions et l'antre de
des convictions d'abord
l'entre-soi c'est l'entre-soi mes amis
qui verrouille la démocratie c'est
l'entre-soi qui abîme la démocratie
je viens c'est vrai et j'en suis fier du
souvenir et pour moi le rôle de la
droite c'est de défendre la souveraineté
populaire pour moi le rôle de la droite
c'est de garantir le respect de la
parole du peuple et bien moi demain je
ne veux pas d'un parti qui se
contenterait de donner des piles de
documents affiches ou tracte à
distribuer je veux un parti qui vous
redonne la parole qui vous redonne une
voix qui vous redonne un bulletin de
vote un bulletin de vote pour trancher
trancher sur les grandes orientations du
parti pas quelques-uns vous les
militants
trancher sur ces grandes orientations
pour que au moins on arrête les
cacophonies les soirs où il y a des
plateaux
tranchez aussi sur les investitures je
veux que demain la commission nationale
d'investiture soit composée pour moitié
des départements et des fédérations pas
de quelques-uns ceux qui connaissent ce
terrain ceux qui connaissent les bons
candidats
et je veux aussi un bulletin de vote que
vous ayez ce bulletin de vote pour
trancher pour la question des
présidentielles bien évidemment pas de
primaire ouverte on a sur ces primaires
ouvertes déjà nettoyés nos statuts mais
pas non plus un vote imposé par
quelques-uns par le Bureau politique
pour moi ça ça n'est pas démocratique ça
c'est soviétique
et ce que je veux
ce que je veux mes amis c'est que demain
le candidat de la droite ce soir le
candidat des militants de droite bien
évidemment je veux que ce candidat ou
puissiez le porter nous le portions tous
ensemble par un scrutin qui sera
absolument clair et je sais très bien
qu'un certain nombre ont désigné ces
primaires la procédure comme la cause
principale de nos trois échecs en tout
cas des échecs à la présidentielle ce
serait tellement facile que ces échecs
viennent des procédures il suffirait de
changer de procédure et alors on
retrouverait le chemin de la victoire ça
serait trop facile souvenez-vous une
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 il a été élu par
l'ensemble des militants et il nous a
offert à l'époque une victoire qui est
une victoire éclatante mais justement
pourquoi mes amis avons-nous perdu en 15
ans 10 millions de voix qu'avons-nous
fait justement de nos victoires c'est ce
qui doit nous interroger aujourd'hui et
donc je veux rompre moi à la fois avec
l'entre-soi l'entre-soi sur les
décisions mais je veux rompros aussi sur
l'entre-deux l'entre-deux sur les
convictions parce que faire de la
politique pour moi c'est assumer les
convictions c'est même aller jusqu'au
bout des convictions de ces convictions
et souvent la droite française nous nous
sommes arrêtés au milieu dans un entre
deux justement
certes bien sûr on a défiscalisé les
heures supplémentaires mais on n'est pas
sorti des 35 heures bien sûr on a fait
les peines plancher mais on a abandonné
la double peine bien sûr bien sûr on a
réduit la fonction publique mais on a
bureaucratisé l'hôpital on a
bureaucratisé la santé avec les ARS on
se réclame du parti gaullisme on se
réclame du général de Gaulle et pourtant
on a contredit le suffrage le verdict du
peuple souverain au moment du traité de
Lisbonne ce que je veux moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est que l'on sorte de cette entre deux
pourquoi mes amis c'est entre deux tout
simplement parce que nous avons eu peur
nous avons eu peur de la bien-pensance
peur du politiquement correct peur
finalement de ne pas correspondre
totalement complètement aux critères de
respectabilité qui souvent sont fixés
par l'hégémonie de la gauche et parfois
même de l'extrême gauche et bien moi je
refuse les intimidations de la gauche je
refuse de céder aux injonctions de
l'extrême gauche je n'ai pas voulu
condamner
la fameuse phrase qui était maladroite
de ce député tout simplement parce que
j'estime que le seul fait de vouloir
renvoyer chez eux les clandestins ça
n'est pas une affirmation raciste
et
[Applaudissements]
mes amis on n'attend pas de la droite
française
qu'elle rétablissent je ne sais quelle
cordon sanitaire on a vu où ça nous a
emmené on a droit on attend de la droite
française qu'on assume les frontières
qu'on assume une vraie politique de
contrôle des flux migratoires et moi je
veux justement faire en sorte que on est
un principe qu'un clandestin qui rentre
en France sache que jamais il ne sera
régularisé je veux qu'on assume une
politique où on puisse assécher les
pompes aspirantes je veux qu'on assume
cette politique
où ça n'est pas au juge de faire la loi
c'est au peuple souverain je pense qu'il
nous faudra modifier la Constitution
faire un référendum pour donner sur
cette question si sensible la parole au
peuple de France c'est à cette condition
que nous aurons justement des mesures
qui pourront permettre d'écarter des
jurisprudences qui nous empêchent
aujourd'hui de maîtriser les instruments
juridiques justement pour contrôler
l'immigration nous nous sommes
dépossédés justement de ces
principes et surtout de ces instruments
mes amis je pense que il faut sortir de
l'entre-soi qu'il faut sortir de
l'entre-deux mais je veux plus que tout
que demain la droite française notre
mouvement notre partie représente un
idéal français représente une espérance
française et que nous puissions répondre
à ce que les français craignent aux deux
grands angoisses françaises l'angoisse
du Grand déclassement économique les
conditions matérielles de la vie le
pouvoir d'achat le niveau de vie mais
aussi une autre angoisse l'angoisse sur
les conditions immatérielles qui
correspond finalement à quelque chose de
l'ordre du mode de vie de nos repères
culturels et pour soigner le malheur
français pour être à la hauteur
et bien il faut répondre à ces deux
grands angoisses simplement en allant au
fond des choses et surtout beau donc
conviction allez au fond des choses
comment répond-t-on aux déclassements
aux déclassement que ressentent les
Français à travers cette appauvrissement
on va au bout des choses c'est à dire
que on ne se contente plus d'aller
soigner les conséquences avec toujours
plus d'argent public on va directement
pour traiter les causes traiter les
causes ça signifie que la France n'a pas
besoin une fois de plus de chèques en
bois de plus d'endettement de plus de
dépenses publiques la France a besoin de
réformes et de réformes courageuses oui
il faudra sortir et assumer de sortir
des 35 heures intelligemment entreprise
par entreprise par la voix du référendum
gagnant gagnant moins d'impôts pour le
salarié moins de charge pour
l'entrepreneur bien sûr il faut sortir
de la société de l'assistanat j'ai
proposé que on puisse fusionner
l'ensemble des minimas sociaux dans une
seul allocation sociale unique qu'on
capte à 70 ou 75% du SMIC pour être sûr
que le revenu du travail sera toujours
très à l'écart du revenu de l'assistance
et puis bien sûr il faut sortir du
royaume du CERFA du royaume du
formulaire des bureaucratisé l'hôpital
l'état évidemment et mes chers amis sur
ce point ne faisons pas de promesses
imprenable bien sûr on est tous ici pour
baisser les impôts mais il faudra sans
doute baisser les infos mais il faudra
surtout et avant baisser la dépense
publique regardez ce qui s'est passé en
Angleterre avec listrus avec des
campagnes et surtout des slogans
inconsidérés je veux que nous soyons
demain une droite crédible une droite
qui une fois arrivée au pouvoir ne
décevra pas et sera la hauteur de ses
promesses première angoisse sur le
déclassement l'autre angoisse allez je
vous le disais au bout de nos
convictions ça signifie quoi nous devons
répondre à cette angoisse de des
possessions culturelles qui prouvent
tout particulièrement les Français du
bas parce que les gens riches ils ont
pas de problème ils ont du patrimoine
matériel et le patrimoine immatériel
pour eux vous savez Régis Debré avait
cette très belle phrase disait pour cela
pour ces gens riches la carte de crédit
sera toujours beaucoup plus importante
que la carte d'identité moi je veux
demain qu'on aille au bout justement de
ces convictions comporte un projet de
civilisation c'est quoi porter un projet
de civilisation
plusieurs exemples il y a deux ans la
France que nous aimons patrie des Droits
de l'Homme a commis une faute contre le
devoir de civilisation lorsqu'on a
enfermé nos anciens dans les EHPAD
lorsqu'on les a coupés de l'affection de
l'amour des siens alors que alors mes
amis que lorsque on arrive au crépulcus
de chez jour la seule raison de vivre
c'est l'affection c'est l'amour des
siens et nous ne l'avons pas compris
nous avons manqué à notre devoir de
civilisation quand on a laissé mourir
seul
des gens qui étaient à l'hôpital quand
on a privé des familles des rites
funéraires la civilisation mes amis
commence justement au moment où débute
les rites funéraires et notre patrie la
France a manqué à son devoir de
civilisation la civilisation c'est aussi
de répondre fermement à l'islamisme qui
n'est plus là sous la même forme qui
tente par ce djihadisme d'atmosphère de
conquérir des quartiers parfois des
écoles mais surtout des esprits il faut
y répondre et je suis fier qu'au Senna
nous ayons voté contre le voile par
exemple pour les accompagnatrices
scolaires contre le voile dans les
compétitions sportives et contre le
burkini bien sûr une politique de
civilisation mes amis c'est aussi lutter
contre l'ENS sauvagement l'hyperviolence
de notre société pas encore une fois
multipliant les moyens ça ne sert à rien
en assumant courageusement une autre
politique pénale pas celle du petit
frère de Madame Taubira monsieur Dupont
pas celle justement de ce laxisme
judiciaire qui consiste par exemple
lorsqu'il envoie au Procureur une
circulaire pour leur demander de
préférer y compris et pas seulement pour
les primo délinquants mais les multi
récidivistes les peines de TIG de
travail d'intérêt général plutôt que des
peines de prison il faudra assumer une
révolution pénale des courtes peines des
doubles peines des peines minimales pour
que la sanction prononcée soit aussi la
sanction mes amis exécutée et enfin nous
ne relèverons pas justement nous ne
relèverons pas la France si nous ne
relèvent pas l'école l'école qui doit
revenir l'école républicaine l'école de
l'égalité des chances l'école du Mérite
l'école où on transmet un savoir où on
doit protéger justement la conscience de
nos jeunes de nos enfants parce que
c'est une conscience en construction je
ne veux pas que les idéologies pénètrent
à l'école de la République qui doit être
un sanctuaire l'islavisme bien sûr je ne
veux pas justement que un professeur une
professeure disait une petite fille tu
devrais jouer plutôt avec un tracteur
étoile petit garçon avec une poupée non
les familles c'est l'éducation l'école
ne doit pas déconstruire l'école doit
mes amis instruire c'est ce que je
revendique et ce sera notre école de la
République l'école de la fierté
française l'école où on donnera à aimer
aux jeunes Français la France mes amis
pour conclure mes amis pour conclure il
y a un énorme affaire effort je veux
vous redonner la parole nous devrons
revenir aussi aux compagnonnage j'ai
fait le tour de France il y a trop de
fédération où il y a plus du tout de vie
y compris de vie de convivialité il faut
contre nous il y a cette amitié qu'on la
cultive c'est important c'est aussi non
pas seulement à travers le débat d'idée
mais à travers ces choses humaines
toutes simples qu'on relèvera notre
famille politique et pour conclure
définitivement je vous dis une chose le
mot fatalité n'est pas un mot français
parce que justement l'histoire de France
ou l'apprend
la France c'est un combat toujours
renouvelé un combat toujours recommencé
contre le fatalisme contre le défaitisme
la France dans l'histoire des hommes et
des femmes c'est ce miracle ce miracle
peuvent surgir des plus grands chaos les
plus beaux sursaut si cette vérité
profonde éternelle à laquelle je crois
que je veux partager avec vous alors ici
devant notre Parlement de notre parti
c'est un nouvel engagement que je prends
que je redis je prends ce serment là
devant vous jamais je ne laisserai
tomber mes convictions vos convictions
parce que jamais je ne laisserai tomber
la France
[Applaudissements]
bien alors je vais commencer Bruno par
la question d'Antoine de la fédération
de l'Aude il est délégué de
circonscription et il te demande si tu
es favorable à la démocratie directe je
suis favorable à l'aide démocratie
directe à la fois pour notre pays et
pour notre partie pour notre pays
d'abord parce que on voit bien que cette
grande fatigue démocratique le fait que
désormais beaucoup de Français des
millions de Français boudent les urnes
c'est tout simplement l'impression
qu'ils ont et ce n'est pas qu'une
impression que le vote quand pour rien
que peut parfois le vote est contourné
j'ai vécu moi par exemple un autre Dame
des Landes une consultation et le
président de la République en réalité
c'est assis sur les résultats je vous
parlais tout à l'heure du traité de
Lisbonne on ne peut pas contourner ce
que dit le peuple souverain quand on se
réclame justement du du gaullisme et
bien je tu dis mes amis je suis
favorable à redonner la parole
directement par la voix du référendum
aux Français il faut mieux articuler la
démocratie représentative qui se fait
par ses représentants députés et
sénateurs avec la démocratie directe et
le premier référendum et le premier
référendum qu'il faudrait faire
précisément c'est sur l'immigration pour
que nous puissions vraiment reprendre le
contrôle pour le parti je vous l'ai dit
je veux des référendum qui tranche les
grandes lignes je pense que c'est une
question d'équité de justice parce que
vous êtes le coeur battant de la droite
mais c'est surtout notre question je
sais que en vous donnant la parole
directement les militants je sais que le
courage sera au rendez-vous parce que je
sais qu'un militant place toujours
au-dessus de ces petits calculs vos
convictions nos convictions c'est pour
ça que pour moi la démocratie interne
que ce soit au niveau du pays et du
parti ce sera la règle
merci une question de Véronique du Nord
conseillère national délégué de
circonscription pour quelle raison les
sénateurs ont-ils accepté le programme
éolien du gouvernement avec pour seule
condition que les éoliennes en mer
soient implantées à plus de 40 km des
côtes
il te reste donc tu pourras la deadline
c'est 11h16 il te reste donc un peu plus
de 20 minutes tu es large
un mot sur cette question là je pense
qu'on partage tous dans notre famille
politique
cette idée que
il nous faut demain une énergie qui
correspondent à quatre critères une
énergie abondante une énergie peu chère
parce que on ne réindustrialisera pas le
pays sans une énergie compétitive une
énergie décarbonée
à cause du réchauffement climatique et
enfin abondante la seule énergie mes
amis qui correspondent à ces quatre
critères c'est le nucléaire Emmanuel
Macron a commis une faute contre la
souveraineté justement énergétique il a
fermé Fessenheim en fermant Fessenheim
il a ouvert Saint-Avold qui va pollué et
qui va accélérer un peu plus le
réchauffement climatique donc pour nous
et nous l'avons exprimé au Sénat la
colonne vertébrale de notre stratégie
énergétique celle nucléaire et ça n'est
pas six EPR qui faut ouvrir c'est au
moins 14 EPR au moins dans un premier
temps et relancer justement manger ses
fans les programmes de recherche Astrid
mais surtout le grand programme j'ai
entendu que la Chine le faisait sur la
fusion nous sommes dans item la fusion
ce sera la révolution des révolutions ce
sera justement
le soleil cette énergie qui sera perpét
et qui ne donnera plus justement de
combustible et de déchets justement
qu'il faudrait retraités première chose
deuxième chose deuxième chose qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des énergies intermittentes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des énergies
renouvelables évidemment on les accepte
mais à des conditions pour moi elles ont
un rôle à jouer qui chez nous ne veut
pas du tout d'énergie renouvelable
personne personne il faut des énergies
renouvelables le rôle a un rôle qui est
un rôle complémentaire d'appoint pas
plus et à des conditions qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait au Sénat 1 on a donné des
conditions pour les maires pour que les
mers sur des documents d'urbanisme
puissent refuser des implantations par
exemple soit d'éoliens ou d'autres
énergies renouvelables deuxième chose on
a imposé un avis conforme des
architectes des bâtiments de France dès
lors que il y a un site naturel
remarquable d'ailleurs que il y a un
monument historique il y aura cet avis
conforme et je pense que c'est un bon
verrou évidemment on a échoué puisque
moi je voulais nous voulions inscrire
dans la loi que l'éolien désormais en
mer soit un éolien flottant à au moins
40 km parce qu'à partir de 40 km il ne
se voit pas et j'étais le président de
cette région des Pays de la Loire qui
pour la première fois est première
région a développé un pilote une
éolienne qui a été d'ailleurs en mer
flottante qui était d'ailleurs de toutes
les éoliennes en mer en France la
première à produire de l'énergie et
d'électricité donc voilà les choses sont
claires simplement on était battus
on est au Sénat 145 sénateurs sur 348
sénateurs et bien il y a des additions
et la politique c'est aussi parfois de
la rythmétique tout notre groupe a voté
pour cette disposition je vois des
collègues qui sont sénateurs que je
salue pour éloigner de nos côtes à 40 km
donc les choses sont simples le texte va
revenir il y aura une commission
xperitaire avec les députés j'espère
qu'on aura la chance de l'améliorer deux
choses l'une où on l'améliore ça
correspond à des critères et on le
votera ou ça ne correspond pas à ce que
je viens de vous dire nous convictions
et le texte ne sera pas voté c'est aussi
simple que ça mais il faut
impérativement se projeter mes amis et
se saisir de la dimension écologique
j'écris moi il y a 18 mois un livre sur
l'écologie je vous redonne le titre
aurons-nous encore de la lumière en
hiver et bien depuis 45 ans pour la
première fois
la France en janvier va sans doute
connaître les coupures coupures de
courant mais les antennes relèvent en
couper vous imaginez l'accès aux
pompiers l'accès aux urgences le
responsable c'est qui cette Emmanuel
Macron et nos députés ont eu raison de
faire une commission d'enquête pour
savoir où sont les responsabilités sur
cette fight énergétique française nous
qui étions un grand pays un grand pays
électronucléaire ou de notre énergie
était peu cher abondante et où on
l'exportait ailleurs en Europe merci
merci alors une question de François
délégué de la fédération de Dordogne
où placer le curseur du libéralisme dans
ce moment de crise
moi je crois pas que il y a un rôle pour
le libéralisme en temps de crise et en
temps de tempête et un rôle du
libéralisme en tant que calme et je
m'explique
c'est pas tellement le libéralisme la
liberté économique et je pense moi que
on a commis par le passé une erreur
parce qu'on a fait l'inverse de ce qu'on
aurait dû faire
les amis pourquoi aujourd'hui la France
est-elle avec la Grèce le pays le plus
désindustrialisé d'Europe parce qu'on a
fait l'inverse de ce qu'on aurait dû
faire
et de ce qu'on fait un certain nombre de
grandes puissances on a verrouillé les
choses en France toujours plus de
formulaire toujours plus de taxes
toujours plus de charges toujours plus
impôts on a donc verrouillé en interne
on a sur administré et au niveau des
frontières de l'Europe on a totalement
déverrouillé et on s'est comporté comme
les idiots utiles de la mondialisation
et bien ça ça ne peut pas tenir vous
avez une incompatibilité entre une
entreprise et une situation où vous
ouvrez tout à la concurrence sauvage de
pays qui ne respectent pas nos standards
standards environnementaux standards
sociaux vous ouvrez nos frontières assez
pays là donc à leur produit qui ont
détruit nos propres emplois donc moi je
pense que la bonne équation c'est la
liberté ici en interne et moi je pense
et la France à une immense
responsabilité quand je vous disais
qu'on n'a pas besoin
et ce que je vois avec Emmanuel Macron
tout avec Emmanuel Macron ce rapporte a
toujours plus de dépenses publiques la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron est une
politique de la dépense publique
certainement pas une politique de la
réforme et bien moi ce que je veux
demain c'est que on puisse se protéger
en Europe avec une vraie taxe carbone je
me souviens avoir lu de très belle
tribune de Michel Barnier dans le JDD
aujourd'hui la taxe carbone c'est rien
c'est sur le ciment c'est sur l'acier
c'est pas ça la taxer bonne c'est une
taxe carbone qui te fera justement être
comme une sorte de droite douane pour
taxer l'ensemble des produits des pays
dont on sait parfaitement que leur
standards environnemental ne correspond
pas à nos propres standards donc une
frontière qui se défend voilà et en
revanche la liberté la pleine liberté
pour nos entreprises qu'on arrête là
encore d'emmerder les entrepreneurs en
France parce qu'on se met des semelles
de plomb regardez ce qu'a fait les
États-Unis avec l'inflation rédaction
acte Lyra les Américains désormais
à hauteur de plus de 365 milliards de
dollars ne financeront ne donnerons de
bonus écologiques que aux voitures
électriques qui seront produites ou
assemblées aux États-Unis et nous
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire en Europe on va
arrêter et on va interdire en 2035 la
vente de moteur thermique
et donc on s'est parfaitement qu'on
n'aura pas les bornes on s'est
parfaitement qu'on aura pas la quantité
d'énergie électrique suffisante et on
sait parfaitement là aussi qu'on va
importer par cargo entier des voitures
qui viendront de Chine est-ce que c'est
ça l'écologie non moi je veux une
liberté économique évidemment protégez
nos emplois protéger nos entreprises je
veux la concurrence je veux une
concurrence mais une concurrence qui
soit le concurrence loyale ce qu'elle
n'est toujours pas aujourd'hui en Europe
une question de Nicolas du Var délégué
de circonscription que pensez-vous des
élus qui s'affichent encore aux côtés de
membres de la majorité il te reste 13
minutes Bruno
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais
je pense mes amis puisque on entre nous
qu'on relèvera pas notre partie notre
famille politique si on n'assume pas une
rupture
il faut assumer cette rupture j'observe
d'ailleurs qu'à l'époque Nicolas Sarkozy
l'avait assumé en des termes beaucoup
plus brutaux que ceux que j'ai pu
utiliser j'ai lu dans la presse que il
avait indiqué que si j'étais élu il
quitterait je lui dis je comprends je
comprends parce que ceux qui évidemment
ceux qui me connaissent savent que je ne
pactiserai pas avec Emmanuel Macron
parce que pour moi
parce que pour moi la politique
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas parfaire j'ai des défauts
évidemment mais reconnaissez moi une
qualité jamais je ne varie en matière de
conviction je les assume jusqu'au bout
et pour moi l'honneur de la politique ce
sont les convictions et quand je dis que
je ne pactiserai pas avec un problème ni
d'ego ni de relation personnelle c'est
simplement qu'on ne pense pas la même
chose c'est simplement que on n'a pas
les mêmes convictions et qu'à partir de
là on doit pas se gâcher c'est ce que
n'ont pas compris tellement les Français
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils nous ont quitté
savent-ils aujourd'hui les Français ce
qu'on pense nous à l'air vraiment moi je
veux redonner une clarté je veux à la
fois clarifier sur les convictions mais
aussi garantir notre unité mais aussi
savoir rassembler parce que on a fait
moins de 5% la présidentielle et si on
veut toujours plus cliver on terminera à
moins de 1%. donc notre enjeu ça sera à
la fois de clarifier d'abord les
convictions mais de rassembler et moi je
ne veux pas que demain Annie notre
partie soit la salle d'attente de tous
les petits ambitieux qui sont justement
les mains jointes pour essayer d'avoir
un plat de lentilles ça n'est pas
possible
bien
dernière question de Sébastien de
Seine-Saint-Denis délégué
circonscription comment faire pour
retrouver une vraie éducation publique
au sein de l'éducation nationale il te
reste 10 minutes et dont une minute de
conclusion si tu le souhaites
l'éducation nationale l'école française
voilà
parmi tous nos plus grands services
publics
le symbole
d'un fiasco pourquoi un FIAC vous
connaissez puisque aujourd'hui chaque
année il y a à peu près 100
000 jeunes qui décrochent un énorme
gâchis un énorme gâchis parce que on
nous avait vanté l'école de la
République
comme étant l'école de l'égalité or
aujourd'hui l'école de la République
française parmi toutes les autres écoles
en Europe et sans doute l'école où il y
a le plus d'inégalités selon que vous
soyez bien né dans une famille aisée ou
moins bien née dans une famille CAPA
beaucoup de moyens vous aurez des
chances où vous aurez des handicaps
c'est insupportable l'école je vais vous
parler il y a quelques instants des
déconstructeurs depuis 30 ans l'école a
été déconstruite par les pédagogistes
nos enfants ont été utilisés comme des
cobayes l'école a été utilisée comme un
laboratoire malheureusement et on voit
aujourd'hui cette faillite et dans cette
faillite là à chaque fois c'est la même
chose c'est les plus fragiles c'est les
plus petits c'est ceux qui sont les
moins forts qui trinquent
donc on a nous un devoir et ce devoir il
est encore plus urgent quand on est
français je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que c'est en France que le pacte
scolaire est le plus imbriqué dans le
pacte national et dans le pacte
républicain parce que nous en France
l'école c'est une double mission bien
sûr la transmission de savoir d'une
grammaire du calcul etc mais il y a une
autre mission cette formée des citoyens
debout c'est d'enseigner la grammaire de
nos valeurs pour que nous puissions
ensemble être une vraie communauté
nationale pourquoi est-ce que la
Troisième République qui réfléchissait
au nom qu'on pouvait donner à ce qui
était jadis les régents les récepteurs
etc à donner le mot instituteur
instituteur parce que à l'époque il
s'agissait d'instituer un nouveau régime
oui l'école de la République a été cet
outil d'institutions justement de la
République des institutions
d'institutions et a été totalement
déconstruite et bien ce que moi je veux
demain c'est que nous puissions refonder
l'école que on puisse la refonder sur
l'exigence l'exigence on ne pourra pas
passer en 6e s'il y a pas un examen pas
pour recaler les enfants mais pour leur
donner des outils il faut prévoir le
redoublement parce que sinon les enfants
les jeunes accumulent des normes lacunes
et ensuite il décroche totalement et
c'est l'échec final donc assumer bien
sûr l'exigence supprimer le collège
unique avoir un vrai bac qui soit un bac
ou on écarte justement les inégalités à
travers le contrôle continu oui l'école
de l'exigence parce que ce sera l'école
de l'effort et donc l'école du mérite et
d'égalité des chances l'école de la
prudence je le disais il y a quelques
instants
les consciences des enfants sont des
consciences fragiles en construction
l'école doit être un sanctuaire et on
doit préserver l'école justement de
toutes les idéologies j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure je suis moi aussi et avec
d'autres favorable à des tenues qui
soient détenus uniformes bien sûr parce
que ça nous permettrait d'offrir un
rempart notamment contre les menés
islamistes mais aussi de lutter contre
cette discrimination sociale lorsque sur
la cour de récréation il y a ceux qui
peuvent se payer des vêtements de marque
et ceux qui meurent fassent payer des
vêtements de marque et enfin après
l'exigence après la prudence la liberté
je pense pas un seul instant qu'on
arrive demain à réformer le mammouth je
pense qu'il faudra plus de liberté il
faudra tirer les leçons justement de ce
que la massification de l'école
française aboutit aujourd'hui à une
impasse il faudra l'école du succès et
donc une école non pas pour tous mais
pour chacun j'ai créé dans ma région par
exemple des écoles de production pour
les décrocheurs c'est une autre péd et
ça permet parce que nos enfants sont pas
des produits standards de s'adapter à
chacun ce sont des êtres humains il
faudra et je le propose je le propose
les Anglais avaient fait les frischools
moi je pense qu'on pourrait dans chaque
département faire des écoles publiques
gratuites autonome avec des vrais chefs
d'établissements tenants qui composeront
leurs équipes pédagogiques qui
choisiront par exemple leurs projets
avec un contrat avec le rectorat seul
cette liberté cette liberté d'un
pédagogie cette liberté de s'organiser
permettra de réformer vraiment
l'éducation nationale pour rendre
justement cette éducation mais
l'éducation et l'instruction publique à
la nation c'est vraiment le plus cher de
ce que je souhaite et je pense que de
tous les chantiers que nous devons
assumer et il y en a plusieurs que j'ai
énuméré tout à l'heure je pense que
relever l'école c'est fondamentale
l'école ne doit pas avoir pour objectif
de déconstruire mais au contraire mes
amis d'instruire et surtout de donner
aux petits Français aux jeunes Français
à aimer la France arrêtons arrêtons de
dire que la France est coupable de tout
arrêtons de réduire notre histoire un
acte d'accusation du passé non la France
a fait de belles choses à donner à
l'humanité de grandes œuvres et bien
demain l'école française l'école de la
République française ce sera aussi
l'école de la fierté française
merci
merci Bruno
j'en profite pour vous dire que en dépit
de la campagne le parti a continué de
travailler on n'a pas fait ces derniers
mois que préparer la campagne interne et
mercredi prochain nous aurons un repère
républicain c'est l'initiative que j'ai
pris sur les grands sujets d'actualité
qui sera dédié à l'école précisément
voilà je referme si j'ose dire l'annonce
paroissiale
alors chers Bruno un mode conclusion tu
as une minute
même davantage puisque tu as jusqu'à 16
normalement donc tu as trois quatre
minutes je vous le disais je pense qu'on
est à la croisée des chemins
trois échecs à trois élections
présidentielles
un parti qui certes à des atouts Annie
le disait notamment notre réseau d'élus
nos militants mais il va falloir tout
reconstruire je crois pas un seul
instant que si on fait mine
de changer on pourra faire quoi que ce
soit il va falloir convaincre les
Français qu'on a vraiment changé l'autre
jour et pour moi c'est important parce
que on dit toujours que la droite en
voulant la réforme voudrait punir les
Français c'est rien de tout ça ce que
nous nous voulons par exemple en matière
de retraite c'est des nouveaux droits
des nouveaux droits pour garantir le
pouvoir d'achat de nos retraités des
nouveaux droits pour garantir les toutes
petites les toutes petites retraites
pour les amener au minimum garanties
dont bénéficie d'ailleurs la fonction
publique un nouveau droit pour encore
une fois redonner une pension de
réversion pour les enfants handicapés
l'autre jour nous étions tous ensemble
sur la tombe du général de Gaulle c'est
un point sur lequel je vais terminer
parce que mes amis la politique c'est
pas seulement de l'économie c'est
tellement d'autres choses
puisque je vous ai parlé de porter un
projet de civilisation et j'ai voulu
rester un peu pour lire
ce qui avait décrit sur les tombes
sur une tombe à gauche il y avait écrit
le prénom et le nom de la fille du
général de Gaulle Anne De Gaulle c'était
un enfant trisomique le général a fait
de sublime déclaration il a dit en
réalité combien ça a été un choc la
naissance de cet enfant mais que ça lui
a permis ensuite d'accomplir et de
trouver la force d'accomplir tout ce
qu'il a accompli lorsque cet enfant
meurt elle est jeune il accompagne à sa
dernière demeure avec son épouse Yvonne
il se penche vers Yvonne il lui dit
désormais elle est comme les autres elle
est comme les autres
mes amis je pense que quand on est la
droite française on a aussi un cœur et
je pense qu'on ne peut pas parler soit
de réforme ou soit d'un projet de
civilisation si on ne porte pas aussi un
combat pour la dignité humaine je pense
que notre monde est de plus envahi par
la finance la financearisation je pense
que nos sociétés sont de plus en plus
soumises aux règnes des technologies et
bien porter en nous porter cette dignité
humaine faire en sorte que on puisse
porter une éthique de la vulnérabilité
une éthique de la fragilité c'est ce qui
demeure nous honorera et nous serons
capables de parler au cœur des Français
à leur esprit non seulement de réformes
économique non seulement porter un
projet de civilisation mais nous serons
aussi capables de leur dire que pour
nous la politique c'est très loin des
petits calculs que la politique c'est
autre chose que les intérêts que la
politique c'est l'homme c'est la femme
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus fondamental
et que j'espère mes amis nous et vous
qui avez connu
vendeur de jour de découragement vous
êtes toujours là je voudrais vous rendre
hommage nous portons cette flamme je
porte cette flamme c'est la même flamme
que nous portons la flamme du courage
cette flamme qui nous tourne vers les
autres qui nous tourne pour aimer notre
patrie la France pour moi ni LR ni la
droite française ne sont un objectif
tout ça sont des moyens sont des moyens
au service d'une cause cette cause c'est
la France la France qui est notre patrie
la France que nous aimons merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]